it is so peaceful and beautiful that
it's hard to imagine anything horrible
happening here
but it did and the effects still
reverberate
september 2012 saddam hilly and his
family leave surrey and come to anisee
on holiday they camp they swim and then
one day
mother father and grandmother are all
shot dead on a quiet woodland road along
with a french cyclist
the police arrived to find a hellish
scene
bodies and bullet casings the family car
reversed into an earth bank in an effort
to escape but there was nothing here to
identify the killer
the family's two young daughters
survived one stumbling around badly
injured the other hiding in the car
under a body
the police investigation grew and grew
mr al hilly's brother was arrested and
then let go and a hunt was launched for
this man a motorcyclist spotted near the
scene
he was eventually found questioned and
released
but earlier this week the same man was
arrested once more raising hopes of a
breakthrough instead he was released
again
and so the specter of unsolved murder
still lingers over this area and its
people what uh
when i saw that a man had been arrested
i was reassured and i thought it could
be him and this case could finally be
solved and now we're back to square one
with a family who'll never know if
anyone will be arrested and found guilty
for these deaths
well nine years ago the villager was in
total shock when we learned that there
had been four murders so it did create
hysteria and mayhem in the village
the hysteria has eased
life has gone back to normal except that
here
everybody knows about the killings
anisee is a popular tourist destination
but this is a pretty remote corner and
as the family drove up the road on a
late summer's afternoon they only seem
to have passed a few people on bicycles
now what happened next is a mystery
why were they killed who killed them and
why was a cyclist murdered alongside
them and after nearly a decade of
investigation
we don't really have any answers
if there was a message this week it was
this
the investigation continues
even after all this time
adam parsons sky news anna c